hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief I'm Erik Bosse joining me today
are Sam basher hello this is me and
Maude Garrett pika that's right nod nod
audio listeners were confused for a
second that's how good your impression
was but today we are gonna talk about a
lot of stuff first off we're gonna be
talking about some interesting
interpretations of caps off screen
adventure at the end of Avengers in game
we talk about what's coming next in the
Marvel Universe and phase 4 and how
in-game might have set up some sequel
options and then we're gonna be talking
about this watchman trailer for the new
HBO series it's gonna be coming out
later this year and which Game of
Thrones cast member might be joining the
MCU
also here's your friendly and weekly
reminder that this show is also
available as a podcast somebody may be
listening on podcast right now good for
you so you can find us on Apple podcasts
the himalaya hap or wherever you get
your podcasts and don't forget to
subscribe to the Westeros weekly feed if
you're a game of Thrones fan and for
Marvel fans we've got a new feed just
for you it's called inside Marvel it's
where you will be able to find audio
versions of all of our Marvel content
and get early access to all that so you
can stay ahead of the game and we want
to give you guys a heads up right now
we're gonna be taking like a couple
weeks off after this episode we're gonna
be we got some new exciting updates to
announce about debrief and in the next
month so to stick around for that we're
gonna come back harder and stronger Eric
needs just a breather it's been a big
big yeah yeah okay let us get started
with our lead story a quick spoiler
warning if you haven't seen Avengers in
game yet but you know what Joe Russo
said this past Monday was a spoiler
window has been lifted and if you've
been following into my mouth social
media you've probably been spoiled so
you're on your own but if you haven't
skip ahead so at the end of endgame The
Avengers were tasked with returning the
Infinity stones to the exact point in
time that they stole them from or else
risk angering told us Winton should
never want to do Captain America steps
up and bravely volunteers himself to
return all the stones himself glory hog
and Avengers endgame screenwriters
Christopher Markus Stephen McFeely were
recently asked how Captain America
returned the soul stone to premiere a
lot of you guys asked us this question
as well concerning premiers complicated
it's based there there's a weird
gift exchange policy there where a life
is required and yet there is no
complications well the screenwriters
response was it's someone else's problem
me theorized but we don't have a
definitive one I do know that there's no
givebacks
it's not a pawnshop you don't get the
soul back when you give the stone back
you're welcome to give the stone back
but it's an everlasting exchange so gave
us some clarity there but there's
someone else in his quote could that be
us we have decided to step up and
bravely volunteer to figure this one out
ourselves until we get some
clarification from from some higher
authority the one above all Galactus
whoever else might have a better
understand this so first I want to ask
you guys how could cap have gotten to
Boromir since it's a new accessory yeah
I mean it is magic if it was breaker he
could buy frost there but Mjolnir
doesn't have the power of the Bifrost do
you need Heimdall for that unless we're
doing comic-book stuff and sometimes
heaps Thor I could just fly through
space because these door this is
realistic time travel through ant-man
holes back in time you know it gets
confusing I like the idea that if
hawkeye left from there you might have
the coordinates so maybe they just
didn't have the coordinates to a former
and they may have had more AG because
nebula knew of that planet she didn't
know where for me or was well that
doesn't make Syd know it's already going
off it's only going off the way they did
it in the second act is they shrunk down
the Benatar which had the coordinates in
it and they maybe just in caps fist we
didn't see it maybe had in a little
pouch on his belt there was a little
Benatar and then he and bigand it once
he went back to a time when he would
need to replace it in 2018 and Biggins a
word now Dickens is in dictionary as
canon it's canon okay so maybe a
spaceship or one idea people are
throwing out there is one of Tony's
suits like maybe he had some kind of
oxygen respiratory system and in some
stark armor and then he flew to for me
or that way could hitched a ride this is
there's a blank hole in this which
really can only be solved with not my
problem
we're the screenwriters if you open this
gate you got a client I do like this
because it's also like you have room to
tell a story now like other writers
could make this make this movie make
this animated short whatever gonna have
you but also it's kind of a fun way to
describe like or explain why cap didn't
come back because he's like do you know
how hard it was to get there I was so I
aged 20 more years before I got to Peggy
I want you so hard we're mere maybe six
months with Peggy like chill out I'm
back right I'm Sam how to throw the
shield
it'll be fine simple way around the the
quantum realm the reason why they can
travel through time is because quantum
realm equals magic they use this you
know physics concepts like the
Schrodinger's cat in Heisenberg
uncertainty principle we can't
accurately measure the velocity or
location of a specific electron and
quantum particles but theoretically if
they can go through any point in time
they should be able to go to any space
in the universe to like space and time
are on the same access access and get
access to any point in time you should
have access to any point in space and
should just be able to use the same
technology what if he gave the reality
stone back he used one yeah that could
be it he could have used the space stone
to get to Vermeer that's simple enough
why didn't they just say that okay yeah
that's what I said yeah you just kind of
drop it god I'm on the map you drop it
in the water he's kind of throw it back
but also I like the idea of him having
to interact with the red school it's
like hmm
you are stuck as a you know Oh a tennety
by yourself being miserable good brings
us to our next question with Peggy
what's that conversation like with Red
Skull the two the last time they saw
each other they were fighting do they
still have a whole thing are they gonna
fight again or is it some people
speculate that Red Skull might not be
there anymore maybe after the we don't
know what happens after someone gets the
soul stone does that relinquish him from
his responsibility as stone keeper does
death that's a forever job someone gets
the stone he's like wow
I gotta be here just in case they want
to return it yeah maybe you got tenure
and I mean they just took it and maybe
he just returned it so like he didn't
have time to disappear also it like cap
has a lot of opportunities now to make
references that he doesn't get it's like
oh it's good yeah you're stuck he's got
like a Lord of the Rings characters like
what's that embarrassing you don't know
that you know get that out here
how humiliating Oxford this is work his
stupid thesis project he was writing
yeah maybe I mean I think we're seeing
the more we dig into this and where we
see why they didn't show this on screen
right because there's just there's too
many ramifications doing the awkward
conversations no it's not and also but I
do get confused because a basic way I
understand the time-travel you don't
need a crack man this in the chat by the
way tonight you don't have to do this is
that the fact that they went back in
time and their future selves being there
is now their president it's not it's not
the past that they had right it's
different but then why can you go put
the stone back at that time period if
you couldn't go back to the actual past
that was there before because now it was
your present what because magic because
that's what it is sorry it was ant-man
shrinking magic my bad sorry there's a
little thing that you do and you don't
make fun of all other time-travel and
say that that's dumb in ours is the
smart one because immediately it's not
critical well here's the thing the
screenwriters brought in real quantum
physicists to consult on the movie and I
think they're just kind of like Oh check
we'll just repeat what they said and
then that will make ours the correct
version of time-travel I don't even have
the same understanding as the directors
and it's not clear if the movie does
violate its own rules of time-travel and
I think it would be okay if they didn't
try to justify it so much yeah by
bringing up thing things like Planck's
constant and inverted Mobius strips if
you just say magic we'll forgive it yeah
it's a Marvel movie we've seen crazier
stuff in the comics hey you just shrink
small enough until you shrink back in
time it's all you gotta say
literally matter after that absolutely
and you know what I get the the
screenwriters and directors plight
though because when you read into their
statements
it was Kevin Feige Swan
make this movie about time travel he
loved the final episode of Star Trek the
the next generation which is all about
different timelines and he's like make
it like that and they're like okay we've
kind of told stories about like
rivalries between heroes from Civil War
Thor infinity war and that's kind of
what we've been more interested in and
you know the thematic emotional arcs but
sure we'll figure out time travel and
unless you have someone who like loves
time-travel logic in a movie they're not
like Rick and Morty the writers could do
a fun time travel story because these
are all nerds who think about time
travel constantly but yeah it's
interesting as a time travel story
infinity war end game kind of leaves
some on the table and leave some loose
ends but hey it gives us stuff to talk
about in videos for that best time
travel in a movie Harry Potter and a
prisoner of azkaban best time-travel you
think that much I mean for me it's back
to the future and be TTFN part two and
this is what this is moments but yeah
those are two different versions right
because in Prisoner of Azkaban it's like
this has already happened I like that
but it's like the movie predestination
the Ethan Hawke movie where it's like
you're everything that we've seen on
screen has already happened it just
loops back on itself yes that's great
and I think technically that's what Game
of Thrones is - if you dig into that I
love it Doctor Who I love you makes no
sense but we do get some clarification
by them saying you don't get the soul
back so Black Widow does not come back
and you don't I had a interpretation in
one of our breakdowns where I thought
that like maybe cap either kept the soul
stone and that's what allowed him to
create a new branch timeline with Peggy
which this with the screenwriters say is
not a new branch timeline a more
confusion there but maybe the idea of by
returning the soul stone he gets like a
metaphorical soulmate and that's why
it's a movie with Peggy and it makes you
say oh that's all that in the jelly's
yeah but then I like the jelly's yep
reference I understood that reference
the reality stone right so that's the
other kind of awkward thing that we
should at least touch on before we move
on the the reality stone is an angry
sludge somehow rocket got it out again
off screen because to awkward
got it out of Jane Foster when she's
sleeping on ass guard they congealed it
into stone form how do they get it back
into Jane Foster when cap and turn it
back into a liquid yeah yeah on Friday
night she likes to knock a couple back
I mean alka-seltzers Mountain water I'd
have no reason to think that this
Infinity stones wouldn't do the same
thing I have no reason to think that
that would not happen yeah you know
there's there's one interpretation than
I read that I liked I was like okay that
makes sense
that the stones have some kind of cosmic
wisdom to them and they know where
they'd be long so if you bring them back
to their time line that they will revert
back to the state of matter that they
were in which in this case is angry
sludge and absorbed back into her body
and you don't have to do anything
different they're like okay actually I
actually have a real it's not a realize
myself that's all just Jane Foster's
Australian for soul stuff you think the
reality stone you can make it any
reality you want there you go
ribbons or blocks or bubbles there you
go that's are the three eyes of three
phases of matter with the reality stone
or really cool slideshows with very
exposition yes oh yeah
well let us know your take on these
questions do you think the screenwriters
owe us more answers do you want to see
this explored in a future Marvel story I
kind of do I kind of do MIT that should
be your epitaph series let's dig into
that question but for now let's move on
to retrieve you a question other
questions shall we buckle up kids it's
time for another episode of this is when
Sam has a trivia question he doesn't
even know the answer to it let's see how
we do you guys know the gist if you're
the winner you get to read out our
goodbyes which is the highest honor and
all the land and the loser the loser
gets pelted with old food no they get
mouthguards that's yeah yeah it's fun oh
here's a no-no because I just saw a hint
of what the question was here we go
question vengers endgame has recently
overtaken Titanic to become the second
highest grossing film of all time the
number one spot is currently held by
avatar how much money did avatar make at
the box office and there we go
sup and you guys both didn't write
answers only I did so I'm already in the
lead go ahead that later but for now
yeah
alright we'd like to give a quick shout
out to one of our sponsors better help a
great service that helps you make a
positive change in your life is there
something that interferes with your
happiness or prevents you from achieving
your goals
if so better help online counseling is
there for you but our help offers
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression
stress anxiety relationships LGBT
matters grief and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential and it's just so
convenient you can get help on your own
time at your own pace you can schedule
secure video or phone sessions Plus chat
and text with your therapist if you're
not happy with your counselor you can
request a new one at any time no
additional charge and best of all it's a
truly affordable option and debrief
listeners get 10% off from your first
month with discount code rock stars so
why not get started today go to better
help hum slash rock stars great let's
move on there was some other news this
week about the future of Marvel what did
you hear about we are in phase 4 of them
see you well at least it's going to take
some shape this week Marvel has
announced the release dates for all the
upcoming movies through to 2022 kind of
following suit with what Disney didn't
but they like went to 2027 not a
competition you guys own each other
pretty much this is fine so the next
three years is what we know so far after
spider-man far from home the next Marvel
movies gonna be May 20 2010 months
that's a big breather that's like a you
know people are still mourning yeah you
know Jake doing all that another movie
in November 2020 and then there's gonna
be three movies in 2021 and three movies
in 2022 so that's eight movies all up
damn straight three movies we've had so
many we were only getting two and then
two an enter an entry yeah so some of
these movies we can expect blacc
panther2 Doctor Strange 2 guardians of
the galaxy 3 Black Widow standalone
movie the Eternals movie and a movie
about shang-chi I had questions Sam gave
me an
so first what do we think we'll see
after spider-man far from home what's
gonna be that one in ten months time
after well we know you mentioned Doctor
Strange too I think I follow a see
Robert Cargill and Scott Derrickson on
Twitter and they're tweeting each other
a lot it seems like there is work on a
script at least I don't know if a script
has been approved at production I think
for small for a smaller film I'd say
Black Widow I'd say that'd be the next
one that we get because it's also it's
not big sci-fi I'm sorry excuse me
CGI action heavy films that need to be
rendered out there close combat action
movies that will take a good amount of
time to capture on camera but you don't
need to be sitting it to a render house
to be creating like like two hundred
thousand original objects and then
rendering them all out over like fifty
thousand server farms like you actually
could make this movie not with a smaller
budget but within less amount of time
would this maybe would you see it is
kind of like the Captain Marvel but in
the naughties instead of the 90s I feel
like it'd be later I mean I order I
guess I think it's got to be before Iron
Man right yeah you're right era maybe it
would be a unless story we've been dying
to know them even 2004 right they're
like Bush era war on terror story where
shield was you know a team America yeah
yeah it's interesting we talked about on
this show this idea that Marvel could be
secretly producing some movie - because
we would have heard about some
production at this point by now we're
less than a year out but we I know that
they're announcing this summer they've
announced that right usual will be and
that's of course it's got be comic-con
yeah it's got it's gonna be great and
it's gonna be a fun announcement
honestly it would be a great reveal if
it's black panther 2 because of the
success of that film and what would you
first range before that but one made way
more money than the other one popular if
they're trying to reassure people hey we
still have a cinematic universe here new
potential leaders I think people might
look more to T'Challa than to doctors
always look at the marketing material as
you can see behind us - Charlie's front
and center and Doctor
strange have to look had to look how to
find him took a moment in the top corner
almost crapped out probably in some
people's Instagram photos didn't make it
in frame I want to just have a little
bit of a moment because this don't
happen often so all right in 2014 I
interviewed Scarlett Johansson for
Captain America Winter Soldier and I
asked her would you ever want a solo
standalone movie and she was like yes if
they asked me I would really want to do
that it's her time she's such a great
character give her a whole movie yeah
yeah girl unfortunately her own movie of
which she will only get one because if
it's a prequel unless they intend on
doing a whole prequel trilogy she has
this whole interesting backstory I can't
believe it's taking this long till they
get her in her own like we got the hint
of the origin story in age of Ultron
they talked about Budapest's Wonder
Woman would have like you know rushed
that's great people love go to see her
in movies would you rather our issue
there and I don't like to compete and
put you know to compete two female
characters together but would you have
liked a black widow before the prequel
before Captain Mal yeah absolutely I
would yeah I mean I Captain Marvel was a
super interesting story but I think they
wanted something but we're not they
wanted to introduce a character to
audiences and black widow people already
kind of had this view of her also brie
Larson's probably you could pay her less
than you pay Scarlett Johansson maybe
it's a money issue oh yeah I mean they
spent a lot recently so also just
sipping this out there we a movie that
could come out pretty quick because of
other studio obligations could be a
Spider Man 3 because it's a your it it
is a minute it is a we're talking about
over a year away and spider-man's still
is pretty cgi heavy sense the costume is
basically fully CGI
at this point which is fine but like
because of so many studio obligations
they might just need to put the movie
out they might need to make a third
movie I mean we have Disney Plus and I'm
still holding out for my conspiracy
theory that one of these Disney Plus
shows is actually a movie in disguise so
no one's patent and I as production for
the Loki series or the captain or the
Winter Soldier Falcon series but they
could actually be movies and we're gonna
be fooled in July when Feige is like
remember that
and what a boring surprise that would be
can't always have cool Christmas
presents sometimes they're gonna be lame
like Monty mentioned six movies what are
some of these other possibilities for
things that end game might because there
was a bunch of Easter eggs and Angie
yeah an end game dude set up some new
characters as well obviously with cap
handing his shield over to Sam and
passing on the literal baton in that
situation so we're gonna see Sam take on
that new instead hopefully in a movie in
addition to the Disney Plus series yeah
yeah them's the rules I want to see them
fighting warring over the shield who
gets to carry on CAPS legacy because and
far from home it looks like it's a big
debate over who gets to carry iron man's
legacy is it Peter Parker Peter
Pretender Jake Gyllenhaal like who's
going to be the new Iron Man in this
universe and I kind of want to see the
other side of explore who's gonna be the
new cap of this universe it doesn't have
to just be one character any other
characters who take on different shades
of the never gonna actually become the
wolf yeah as he wasn't what was it just
a cutscene or four seconds over like
maybe I get it we hear the name now
that's not a name of a terrorist what if
all what is they all what what if they
do classic sitcom were like Oh mom and
dad are flying so they put tape down the
middle of the house and mom has this
side dad has this side but they do that
was the shield I mean I only get half
the shield at a time I'm not idle stop
pitching I want you to keep pitching
we're gonna I mean when you check out
like our breakdowns of the end game
movies there was like little possible
hints ed name or possible hints at the
x-men existing in the school okay yeah
lilah Barton for sure quick question who
owns Namor isn't that you know like they
always do like that fun that Venn
diagram Bob right like these people
around here like she-hulk is still owned
by Universal but Hulk is Cher pork with
universe oh yeah you can share yeah
holding share that's why he only has
team-up movies yeah you can't be in his
own movie with his title in the name and
like Namor always I felt like it's like
a Lionsgate or somebody like somebody
somebody else has that but I would like
him in the movie
I've always felt weird about that never
knew what they are supposed to do with
that
American movie would be cool Captain
Marvel - you have so much cosmic stuff
to go play with and it's still full
going to be guardians 3s guardians of
the galaxy you're probably gonna get
actually eternals probably make sense -
cuz like they're doing so much casting
right now like let's just keep it going
you know I just keep that keep that
train chugging it seems like multiverses
the name of the game though like that
hint in the spider-man far from home
trailer this week it's really like
actually this universe that was already
pretty wide open we're gonna open it up
to like several more dimensions wide
openness I liked the multiverse the best
in so far spider into the spider thank
you tweet this week where it was like a
shot of animated it's like see you in
another universe were thinking maybe
Miles Morales will cameo oh hey Artie
when someone was like who did the Iron
Man graffiti on the wall and was like
that was miles that was a great idea
I've been great he does already exist
there Aaron Davis Donald Glover played
him and in homecoming and he cuts he
talked to him talking to miles on the
phone saying he wasn't gonna make it you
know like it's there there's a lot of
and also here's the path being totally
clear when they said like six one six
and that was also in spider-verse it's
like let's just not get too hung up on
what that means like just let let's let
it be things you know it's okay overall
I think probably turtles are Black Widow
but it'd be interesting know what you
guys think but also this week we got a
teaser for the new Watchmen series
coming to HBO from the people behind
leftovers and lost it's very exciting we
learned that this show is set after the
events of the graphic novel and Zack
Snyder's film adaptations gonna be very
interesting to see which one they pull
from probably the novel so Rorschach is
dead of course but his journals have
inspired an army of masked vigilantes
boy howdy that's scary and older
Ozymandias is showing up and now played
by Jeremy Irons which is great otherwise
no sign of any other heroes or
characters that survived the graphic
novel so we thought like we'd speculate
on what happened between the original
story and this show so is reminding the
original comic and movie adaptation ends
with Ozymandias plotting to end the cold
war between Russia and the US by
destroying most of New York or either
blaming it on or and either blaming it
on a psychic alien or
to Manhattan so those are those are your
two options you can pick whichever one
you want showrunners what do you guys
think did I see Mandy is's plan work
well I messed up the word so I just
tried to go with it sounds like if this
world still exists Ozymandias this plan
must have worked to some extent because
if if no one believed that that dr.
Manhattan in the movie or if the alien
monsters destroyed or an extra external
threat if no one believed that then we'd
be back in the middle of the Cold War
and then Russia and the United States in
that version of history probably would
have destroyed themselves so that at
least there must have been some
powers-that-be who accepted Ozymandias
as hoaxes but it looks like the way
they're depicted now or the followers of
abortions are like kind of these
anonymous like a conspiracy theory
organization or the people who like leak
stuff you know anonymous with their
that's a great point it seems like
they're kind of like a subversive group
who not many people take seriously but
are gaining momentum and now they're
threatening the world of Ozymandias
would not be out of place if they were
all Joker masks and this was Gotham I'm
getting such strong Gotham vibes from
this noticing some key characters from
the first Watchmen the movie that we're
not really seeing here and I'm missing
it honestly I think they're kind of
saving themselves just a tiny bit
because like it awesome anteus makes
sense because he was the one behind the
master plan and to explain how the world
works now you might need to have someone
like that as like and also Jeremy Irons
is such a good get like as someone I
think playing it there you go boom a
billion Internet points in the comments
down below I was good I was a good one I
like it because also you bring up a good
point that they obviously published
Rorschach I recently reread Watchmen
just because I'm doing a book club for
it and it
they obviously publishes notes and
people know that
Ozymandias did plan this but also
because of how connected he was and how
instantly the world calmed down from the
Cold War tensions that people would side
with Ozymandias
and try to quell that and basically say
that and discredit that newspaper and be
like that's not true also it's Rorschach
that dudes a maniac why would you
believe a convict yeah yeah yeah the
it's interesting how maybe we're gonna
ask ourselves why now like why is this
show like how is Damon Lindelof gonna
make it a show that reflects our current
events and our current times and the
whole idea of discrediting print
newspapers is very big right now so you
can imagine how in a fictional universe
some people can just easily say oh it's
fake news don't read it as wise would
you rather live in peace right now even
if you were lied to
yeah fine and I can easily see a society
accepting that if it meant no nuclear
annihilation where does dr. Manhattan
gonna fit into all this especially since
he got his revamping DC's rebirth as
well just like that character has been
it's interesting to run all over in the
movie he he left he departed earth right
he went to meet delay he left the
universe yeah he's gone he's gone
another state of being yeah so it kind
of works better dr. manhattan's such an
interesting thought experiment cuz it
really applies like the Superman logic
to the state of affairs and what if
Superman really did work for the US
government and like murder Vietcong and
decimate it allowed us to win Vietnam
but also the way Alan Moore applied that
to that story and in the story as soon
as he leaves Russia invades Afghanistan
it like immediate immediate because of
how like he is the nuke pointed at
everybody as soon as he is gone
everyone's frankly your deterrent yeah
that's what you get super scary yeah and
we we should also throw some predictions
right now for Regina Kings character I'm
very excited to see cuz she's like she
is one of the protagonists from this
show also super excited to see Don
Johnson in a in a property like this
it's so interesting great name to say to
note video with the cap talks you guys
Oh long Johnson
honestly I when it comes to different
like yeah I what I hope for is that
Watchmen characters are based on
Charleston Charlton comics and that's
like you Blue Beetle and you're get
Captain Atom I don't know if anyone
likes those characters but they're great
and they're new adaptations of it so if
this was pulled from a Charlton
character that'd be really smart and a
really fun nod to comic fans but also
it doesn't matter that much because it
could just be something that's for comic
fans and then just allows for an
interesting and unique story to tell in
this post Watchmen world so I'm on board
with it all so it looks like the night
owls ship is crashing sure yeah it's
it's fascinating the I love that the
tick-tock
kind of imagery to it it reminds us of
like the nuclear clock that was the
common image recurring image in the
first or in the graphic novel and I mean
I'm just hoping that this is a huge hit
because like something's got to keep me
on HBO right now I mean I love
Chernobyl's killing it right now so
there's good content but I need like a
big crazy my bad well anyway so let us
know what you think about this in the
comments below
is this gonna be your next big show
let's hope so but what else happened
this week well detective Pikachu came
out that's right with Ryan Reynolds
starring as the voice of Pikachu and the
reception has been really really
positive but then the score on Rotten
Tomatoes not so hot yeah maybe
audiences are on board critics aren't oh
yeah it's real fun the game will have a
breakdown to that coming out on Monday
sure we missed hey rumor has it that
Michael Rooker who's yondu from
guardians of galaxy aka Mary Poppins
[ __ ] may play king shock in James
Gunn's Suicide Squad reboot have you
seen a picture of what this could look
like it's basically a man with no neck
over the head of a shock Sam is a great
person thumbnail for you CWU has finally
dropped its first teaser for Batwoman
starring Ruby Rose she did go on to
tweet a story saying that it's coming
out in full and then immediately went hi
is it I did I maybe it's not it maybe it
is I'm not sure I forget I ever said
anything so expected in fall and Richard
Madden aka Robb Stark
okay they were first king of the north
is in talks to play a role in Marvel's
eternals movie second who else
Angelina Jolie
and Johnny McConnell to the king of the
north don't know
yes well I'm excited to do some
whitening is me oh cool all right I
didn't know I was doing this part let's
go ahead and hop in gang you guys know
lightning round we tweeted out asking
for questions you guys sent them in and
I'm gonna be throwing them at my car so
they better buckle up oh you both I've
always buckle Oh interesting well
without having a baby car let's go ahead
and get started first questions for old
Sam from Gino LOL any advice for copping
coping with post endgame stress lesson
face for anxiety watch bury you won't
feel less stressed it's just a very good
show and i need people to talk about it
with eric we have a question here from
one f jay cohen your infinity war
breakdown did a great job of showing how
the villain was the protagonist do you
think Marvel will try to build on this
and give us a movie focusing on a baddie
and will and which villain would you
like to see get their own movie and
phase for Doctor Doom is my easy answer
for that one but yes thank you for your
compliments yeah I think I would love to
see a more complex view of a protagonist
because protagonist don't have to be
characters you root for as it looks like
they're gonna be showing with Joker this
fall or this October and there's been
plenty of TV shows where the bad
curcumin berry characters who do morally
bad things but you kind of sympathize
with their journey and the interesting
Doctor Doom and I hope they do it
lightning more we got a question here
from Anna eo2 do you think we'll see our
DJ appearing as a hologram going to be a
flashback and though you CGI again whoa
and next we got one for Sam that's me
from a legend of cotton with the Fox
merger well x-men character would you
like to seek at their own so long movie
gambit no I will go with multiple man I
am say the name right because I just
want to see I like the idea of doing a
roommate comedy like that Michael Keaton
movie where he started cloning himself
when they start getting publicity
multiplicity 3 he was an x-men he was he
had quite a chewed on him he did it he's
a resident bad boy he did or Kitty Pryde
movie Maude Weaver
question here who was your dream
fantastic forecasts from Jason oh no one
recently and I was like yes yes yes it
was Eva Mendes as Susan storm it was
Oscar Isaac as everybody yeah there you
go that's my answer
all the boys it's the brother the
husband in-law whoever it is from
breaking bad as the Michael Chiklis is
the DA and then they go and then be good
Johnny Human Torch I think I forget but
like Sam yeah
alright we got another question here
that's good as good I would love to be
Johnny Storm Eric we have a question
here from adamantium do you think
professor Hulk will get his own movie
and what's the deal with his right arm
now do you think it'll heal back to
normal after the snap ooh a good
question unfortunately I don't think
Professor Oak's gonna get his own MCU
movie just because of those rights
issues that we talked about for maybe if
Comcast decides to team up with their
archrival Disney we might see some team
up movie where we can get a Hulk movie
again I don't think it's gonna happen
anytime soon but maybe he'll be in
another Thor movie a Guardians movie
pretty cool because he existed would
that explain the we'd relationship
stroking palms but I think his right
arms gotta heal right because I'd be or
maybe we just explore Hulk in an
alternate timeline where you did or
maybe he just gets a fun long sleeve
t-shirt I'm really quick question from
ATS ambassador what we have one quick
question
oops I forgot it alright time for 50
seconds I'll think about it would we get
to the 52 second chat or air go ahead
yeah well we all have 15 seconds to
shout out plug ramble about anything we
want I'll give you some time mod you
have 15 seconds to shout out or plug
anything yeah I want to shout out to
sambasiva because he's actually been
making some television recommendations
over the past years and I finally
started listening to
Berry is an exceptional TV show I'm not
up to season two yet so don't spoil for
me but I'm get there and I've just been
watching new girl and you're like it's
so good and I was like I watched an
episode it wasn't great and you're like
it is and now it is I yes you're right
Sam you're right for my 15 seconds yeah
those recommendations I agree with
Chernobyl I mentioned before oh yeah
Kremlin it no it's it's such a good show
and in addition to watching the show
download the trinova podcast is the the
head writer of the show Craig Mazin
teams up at the Peter sagal of wait
don't tell me and break it down even
more so it's like double the episode cuz
you've learned all the background
research that went into it what was real
what was adapted and it's equally as
haunting and horrific but fascinating to
learn this history I didn't I didn't do
it all right what did you do alright my
15 second shot is to go to youtube.com
slash might be awesome cuz I did a deep
dive explaining what it would be like to
live with Pokemon and I had to read a
lot about insurance and I wish that paid
off more so go watch that video please I
am begging you to watch that video if
your Pokemon what would you be her
cyndaquil he is a little noodle that
runs around and then makes little
explosions come out of his back he's
always like fiery noodles yeah fire
noodle that's why I wrote in pokemon
gold you can add me if you're on my
discord are we doing this to him yeah he
pulled off well all right time for a
trivia question my trivia question fella
there he with the flowers yes she
doesn't have fingers she just says
flowers for hands there we go
alright let's go ahead and read that
question one more time buckle up gang
here we go
Avengers endgame has recently overtaken
Titanic to become the second
highest-grossing film of all time the
number one spot is currently held by
avatar Blu people won how much money did
avatar make at the box office
alright quick Oh Sam yeah says 2.7
billion dollars woo mod says too much
billion dollars
and Eric said 1.2 billion dollars
mine too we have an answer here is it to
your closest 2.8 billion
whose howdy duty to Sam I am the winner
and we salute you Sam for your hard work
thank you thank myself I was so all
right so here we go here we go really
good you guys know the rules Eric's got
to put the thing in his mouth and I've
eaten popcorn there there you go we'll
help you get it out of there and you're
gonna have to go and read the goodbyes
what I also reiterate Goethe might be
awesome please for the love of God I've
got so much money into it so close to
the right answer do the alphabet really
quick that's what you're saying kill me
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the audio in videos I got it
as I guns leader this video is that
YouTube / new rock stars any get the
audio anywhere you get your hard tests
and use it anyway as you get actually
the consoles only actually less drugs
either hun Khan and Tina side near
oxides like then subscribed any access
deep dives and anything you love I know
Mars Attacks alien
[Music]